i think that dave chappelle has got you
know was honoring st
and i get that
he's not right about everything right it
doesn't matter the fact is if you let
the mob come for this guy they will come
for you just look at what they're doing
with the vaccine mandates now about
taking people's ability to make money
away right you have to have this vaccine
or you no longer have a job what do you
think that's going to do to thousa not
tens 20s hundreds of comics that can't
say this stuff but thousands and
thousands and thousands of people who
can no longer make a living for their
family people don't understand this when
they say well really what's what's your
line in the sand really is it a vaccine
mandate where you can't work or really
it's your where someone says that you
can't tell an offensive joke just so you
understand we are talking about with a
vaccine mandate removing someone's
ability to work to provide for their
family we are talking about when you
demand a special be removed and you call
up every club and this happens all the
time and you say hey don't book this
person you are removing their ability to
make a living for their family do you
understand that as far as every war
waged ever up until
maybe the 19th century
that was enough
do you realize people just fought for
land so that they could actually work